today I'm opening my very own bank
setting aside 11 million pounds to
challenge the High Street Banks who are
profiting at the expense of ordinary
people I was broke living in a counselor
State just over 10 years ago now my net
worth is over 20 million pounds and
today I'm going to be giving away one
million pounds I've got a few tricks up
my sleeve to cause a real commotion and
trust me you don't want to miss what
happens next
[Music]
when I was a teenager I wanted to get
into property development I went into a
bank and they laughed at me and told me
that I was too inexperienced in property
to be able to gain out loans so now I
wanting to set up a bank to help
Ordinary People Get on the property
ladder bye tell you to save up your
money and give it to them and you know
what they do with it they invest it in
property and one of the backs have
recently said that they want to be the
biggest private landlords in Britain so
I was thinking you want to compete with
me I'm going to set up my own bank and
compete with you
time for the customers to flood on in
foreign
well this is a bit disappointing
I think I need to be a bit more
proactive with my marketing it just so
happens that our bank is actually next
to Lloyd's Bank by chair coincidence I'm
gonna go and just see what's going on
and raise some interesting awareness
yeah guys
hi ladies hey we just set up a finance
company we're giving out loans I'm
giving out loans
you know what let me just tell you
something real quick today serious we're
giving out a million pounds today
they've clocked me already they're all
looking at me through Lloyds I'm in
there my logo's not got a horse on it
that's a deer the horse can't patent the
color green oh
oh no
oh thank you brother I appreciate that
that's all right you leave it alone by
the way
all right bro thank you all the same
I think this is gonna be hard I don't
know if I don't know if it's gonna work
that well we've got a bank it's just
opened up down the road if you need a
loan come and speak to us
what up Instagram I got crazy news I
just started my own bank if you're a
property investor you want to become a
property investor and get your deals
financed come down right now let me give
you finance I'm giving out a million
pounds today come come come so whilst I
waited for the masses to come I had a
special challenge for my very first
customer
so
I'm gonna make you a challenge if you
can guess
how much money is in here you get to
keep it
but 250 pounds you think 250 pounds yeah
yeah I have to click this yes oh wow
poor Piggy
five six seven eight nine ten let's
check on him later on in the video as my
post online about the grand opening of
my bank giving away one million pounds
today had caused a commotion outside all
right guys come and former Q let's go
welcome to my humble office what can I
do for today
nice to meet you hello hi okay well I've
recently purchased a proxy from auction
it's a three bed and I'm hoping to
renovate that so what did you need from
me then the money's for the refurb it's
000 and I've got the bills out who's
done the schedule of works and he's
ready to go it looks like a great deal
yeah is this your first yeah it's our
first deal have you already put an offer
on it we offered one or five how much is
the refurb needed 30 000 and what's the
end value 190. wonderly are you still
counting 145. are you still counting yes
you're taking a little while you know I
mean this is like off putting with us
can you just count a bit quicker how
much is it worth it's it's currently
worth three five two and how much do you
have the option to buy it for it's 127
900 pound off of the house that's what
the council's given yeah presumably
though you can do this with no money
down because you can just use the
discount of the deposit exactly so what
do you need what do you need the bank
for I wanted to do an extension
extension
I was really impressed with the deals I
was being pitched but it was my next
customers that had the most property
knowledge so what can I do for um we
need loans
legally
we can't give a loan kids yeah
I've watched all your lessons and we
went to viewings and we're going to look
for a loan I want to think creatively of
a way that I can help you guys because
to be honest I love your vision
um
I'll speak to your mum as well about the
idea of potentially we could maybe give
your mom a loan yeah yeah yeah get
yourself some lunch on me as well thanks
thank you enjoy
I'll see you soon good to meet you you
guys are going to be very successful
wonderly What's Happening Here I started
again
oh my goodness selfie Matt when I'm
trying to do interviews here you have to
count a little quieter you know just
count a little quiet the bank is still a
small Bank
yeah you might notice it's called Samuel
Leeds finance and not Samuel Leeds Bank
the reason for that is because bank is a
protected word so we couldn't register
it at hmrc but we're operating as a bank
in the sense that we're giving loans out
but we're not taking people's money
we're giving money but it's strictly
business to business for property
investment and property development now
that I had my own bank I wanted to see
what the general public opinion was on
their Banks do you trust your bank to be
honest I don't really think I trust my
bank it's really uncertain if one day
they can like close our accounts what do
you think about the fact that it's
easier to get a bank loan to go on
holiday or to get married than it is to
invest in a property
yeah that's that's that's pretty bad did
you know that the bank uses your savings
for their Investments and what do you
think about that I didn't I didn't know
that and I think it's a bit it's a bit
sneaky yeah so you put money in the bank
yeah keep it safe they invest it I think
it's Sneaky I don't if I don't know then
I should know it's my money right it's
got hidden agendas clearly I guess what
do you think about the fact that Lloyd's
Bank have said publicly that their goal
is to be the largest private landlords
in Britain so the fact that a bank wants
to own as many you know homes as
possible you know that's going to drive
prices up and that's definitely not good
news for younger people round eight to
six 187 198
uh 188 189. after hearing all the great
deals and pitches it was now time to
start shaking hands and writing checks
so why is this deal important that this
this happens my wife and I Jessica uh
we've been trying for a child for about
17 years and a couple years ago I
decided we would go to Ukraine and have
a surrogacy but dude my job I'm not
allowed to go to Ukraine anymore this is
your baby
so I've got to get in there get this
project done and get out again and then
you're going to get your baby baby and
then I can give up my job because they
won't let me go to Ukraine
so you needed this deal more than
anything right now how confident are you
in this deal as an investment 100
confidence that's good I'm glad you're
confident because I am confident too so
that is approve my friend thank you so
much
seventy thousand
I'm pleased to say that in principle
that is approved my brother okay thank
you let's get that house well I've seen
your application form obviously if both
changes confirmed everything and I'm
happy to say that is approved
so congratulations well my friend I'm
very pleased to say
approved
thank you very much congratulations
can't wait to see this one um but I'm
gonna rednecks I'm buzzing with it
myself mate so
yes thank you very much congratulations
how much was it I it was 201. 201 and
you said 250 yeah which means you were
close enough yeah so you get I think you
get to keep it well okay
[Music]
come to Leeds Bank respect Brothers
thank you so much
so I've now approved one two three four
five six loans and we've only got
another oh my goodness I've only got 55
000 pound left
so I can maybe give one small loan left
hello you must be mom to these awesome
kids
that you are also in property and might
need a loan exactly what's it for it'd
be for a two-bedroom house yeah purchase
and refurbished and have you seen the
property it's in really bad condition
it's like the worst house on the best
Street
yeah your mom's smart oh no she is well
here's how much I could put in yeah 80
of the purchase which will be 38 400.
okay nice so if that was something you
wanted to go ahead with that would be
alone approved in principle amazing
congratulations thank you good to see
you man I look forward to seeing you
again soon we're going to spend the day
together
yeah God bless
so the reason I chose some of your leads
is I've developed the level of trust in
Samuel I follow him and see everything
sort of thing stands for and his
percentage and interest is also really
reasonable especially in this current
day and age yeah he's more of a role
model to most of us because he's one of
the reasons we kind of wanted to become
interested in property investment and
that's what we want to learn from him
he's a very big inspiration
I can't believe I gave away a million
pounds today although I didn't give away
a million pounds I invested a million
pounds into people's deals not just into
their deals but also into the people
behind the deal so it was an incredible
day if you want to get in on the action
and you want me to help you get into
property I'd love to spend a full day
with you teaching you all the basics of
how to find good deals that are ready to
be financed one pound come and spend the
day with me at the property investors
crash course I'll leave a link in the
description let's meet up let's do
business until next time peace out
oh
yes I can
oh yes I can
[Music]